doctors these are the people we run to
when we are a little under the weather
or when we slightly dying - they've
trained for years and should be trusted
right while in video games anyone can
slap dr in front of their name and voila
dr. Robotnik comes to mind today's list
is dedicated to five doctors you should
not trust with your life dr. Ned is
probably the most approachable doctor on
this list even though he has killed more
people than Harold Shipman when we first
meet the doc he lets us help with an
operation which of course we mess up all
right make a small incision just the
lowest sternum but be careful we don't
want to Nick the coronary artery
sadly for us the dock goes a little off
the rails in the DLC and we are forced
to strike him off the active doctors
register oh and then he comes back again
as an undead doctor and you kill him all
over again dr. J s stamen of the
Bioshock series was a well respected
cosmetic surgeon before his move to the
ocean floor over the years in rapture
his obsession with beauty took him a
little off the rails but his enthusiasm
always remained how dare the doctor call
you ugly
take him down he doesn't deserve to live
did you know there's a doctor in
Resident Evil 4 well he doesn't look as
clean-cut as you'd think his stethoscope
is a little chain sorry and his white
core is a little dirty and wrapped
around his head his speciality is curing
headache which he can remedy in a single
second
what a guy that dr. Salvador's
dr. Mario what a cute and lovable doctor
and before the PlayStation fanboys jump
on this list yes we do acknowledge and
intend Oh Xbox and PC games sorry to
disappoint but don't worry we love
playstation above all else anyway I
digress
in the aptly named dr. Mario series your
job is to run medication down the throat
of your patient until all bacteria has
gone yes Mario advises pill-popping
to the brink of death maybe get your
stomach pumped before leaving this
hospital and typically his brother is
getting in on the act to back off Luigi
forge your own path in addition to this
dr. Mario moonlights as a member of the
Fight Club he told me the first rule
once but I forget
so we've reached the top of the
malpractice list and it's headed up by
new insurgent simulator
your job is to simulate what a surgeon
does well that was far easier to explain
than I expected but to be more specific
you will be removing lungs hearts eyes
and brains as you propel up the insane
doctor leaderboard the problems really
begin when you realize your hands are
about as useful as chopsticks on a frog
but the most satisfying element happens
once you've scooped out all of your
victims
I mean patients brain and simply drop in
a fresh one
this proves that brain surgery isn't
really rocket science so that was our
list do we miss any of your favorite
surgeons physicians or Gynaecologists
please sound off below if you enjoyed
this video please give us a like and
help us reach more people by subscribing
to our tiny Channel this is Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time
you